[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour je suis super content d'être ici
avec vous ce soir en bas de l'amphi dans
lequel j'ai fait mes classes
alors quand j'étais étudiant et qu'on
était content on a eu plusieurs moyens
d'exprimer notre joie est un des moyens
c'était d'utiliser les pupitres que vous
avez devant vous alors j'aimerais
réaliser un petit rêve ce soir que j'ai
depuis quelques années avec vous grâce à
vous la maintenant c'est de savoir ce
que ça fait quand on est en bas de l'an
viii
quand est-ce que fermer un petit peu
plus finement que quand on est étudiant
on va se le faire partir de salle et on
va se faire en gérant les volumes vous
allez voir ça va être très très simple
vous êtes prêts après 4 mettez vos mains
sur les pupitres alésia les ia les i
tout le monde merci 4 3 2 1
on y va allez-y
alors je suis d'autant plus heureux
d'être là maintenant que j'ai réalisé un
petit rêve et que du coup je sais qu'on
peut les réaliser
merci à vous et je suis d'autant plus
content d'être là qu'on vient de toucher
du doigt à tous ensemble quelque chose
qui est extrêmement important pour nous
les humains la cohésion le lien qui se
tisse dans l'action de groupe
la connexion instantanée qu'on a eu l'
accès dans cette salle je parle de la
connexion qui fonctionne quand il ya
plus de batterie plus de réseau plus du
wifi ça ça vous parle aussi sympa on a
tous une galère de batteries fini on est
rentré dans une société 2.0 post
révolution numérique cette révolution
numérique qui mondialise toutes nos
sociétés qui digitalise les process qui
horizontale is l'information et qui
combinait avec les nouvelles générations
les digital natives entraîne des
changements de paradigmes profond dans
toutes les structures sociales
la famille est aussi là on passe le plus
clair de notre temps au taf dans les
entreprises et dans les organisations
publiques
la révolution numérique entraîne de
facto une révolution managériale et ça
se sent déjà hier on parlait de carrière
aujourd'hui on parle de slasher on
commence à en parler
hier on parlait de silos dans les
entreprises aujourd'hui on parle de
décloisonnement de transverses
hier on parlait de chef
aujourd'hui on parle de scrum master
hier on parlait de hiérarchie et
aujourd'hui on commence à parler de la
crise alors transversale children au lac
racines un peu flipper tout ça en fait
tous ces concepts qui sont dans la
révolution managériale recouvre une
seule et même idée clé c'est que plus la
technologie s'installe et prend en
charge l'exécution des tâches silo plus
nous les humains elle nous amène à
travailler en relation les uns avec les
autres
la révolution managériale et celle du
développement des compétences
relationnelles
de nos compétences relationnelles alors
développer les compétences
relationnelles c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué parce que les humains c'est
pas des machines
tous ceux qui gèrent des équipes vous le
diront on télécharge pas un plugin pour
être à l'aise prendre la parole en
public dans un groupe de travail on
télécharge pas un plugin pour gérer ses
émotions ont tiré parti qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors pour développer les
compétences relationnelles
il ya un maître mot il faut expérimenter
pour développer cette compétition ont
fait pas de la cohésion de groupe et on
n'apprend pas à gérer son langage non
verbal en restant quatre jours
assis devant un powerpoint si je suis
aidé soit il est avec la prise de notes
si faible soit elle il faut vivre une
expérience vivre une expérience
clairement alors attention je parle pas
d'une expérience qui marquent au fer
rouge toute sa vie un genre chalet
filtre de la communication non je parle
d'une petite expérience cool relax un
truc qui permet de faire tirer des
petites conclusion à tout le monde qui
permet d'ouvrir les portes derrière
lesquelles se trouvent les leviers qu'on
va actionner alors un truc qui parle à
tous ses biens mais cette petite
expérience il faut qu'elle respecte 3.1
faut qu'elles soient simples
préhensibles 2 faut qu'elle soit
illustrative et 3 faut qu'elle parle à
tous alors un truc simple illustratif et
qui parle à tous on en est depuis la
nuit des temps qu'on a largement
occultée en occident c'est le rythme
difficile à définir le rythme il nous
parle à tous c'est la première chose à
laquelle on a accès avant notre
naissance encore bercée dans la muse
maternelle c'est aussi la dernière chose
à laquelle on se réfère avant de
s'envoler et entre les deux il gère tout
ce qui nous entoure et gère tout ce que
nous faisons nous vivons grâce au rythme
des saisons
nous vivons grâce à notre rythme
cardiaque à notre rythme respiratoire
nous sommes soumis à nos rythmes
circadiens mieux que ça
nous sommes sensibles au rythme d'un
discours nous observons un rythme de
groupe pour pouvoir s'y adapter le
travail on a bon riz ou pas après vous
faites ce que vous voulez le rythme est
un levier puissant pour développer les
compétences managériales les compétences
relationnelles
pourquoi parce qu'il est simple il est
maître dans l'illustration de choses
très complexes comme la complémentarité
des profils ou comme le langage non
verbal ou comme le leadership et pour
autant il parle à tous alors laissez moi
vous présenter deux de mes outils que
j'utilise beaucoup dans mon travail de
formateur
le premier c'est le zengo vous l'avez
entendu au début
petit cocorico c'est français c'est très
joli j'adore ce truc le son est doux et
entraînant n'est ce pas un peu comme
devrait l'être un bon esprit d'équipé
quoi le deuxième c'est une petite
merveille de technologie moderne tactile
il fonctionne au toucher et répond à la
nanoseconde
il n'a pas son pareil pour matérialiser
ce qu'est le ried à ce titre là il
fédère il permet d'échanger
il permet de communiquer
[Musique]
alors alors maintenant que vous n'avez
plus les mains vides et que l'on vous a
montré un petit bout du chemin
c'est à votre tour d'expérimenter le
ride on va le faire tous ensemble mais
entendu et on va commencer par vous
présenter de son le son sourd et le son
clair le son sourd pour ceux qui ont des
djembés il se fait avec la main au
milieu de la peau posez votre main au
milieu de la peau tout ce qu'on me donne
des idées les et les y voilà
pour ceux qui ont les shakers la main va
venir entourer le shaker complètement
pour éviter que les billes taillée au
millimètre résonne entre le plastique
ok une tape une tape sur les djembés un
chick seul shaker après 4 ok 1 2 3 après
ça veut dire en 5 ok on y va 1 2 3 4 3 4
3 4 3 4 3 4 3 4 3 3 4 4 4 4 4 4
[Musique]
alors avant de passer à la deuxième
frappe deuxième son le son clair ce que
je vous sens un peu tendu là alors on va
bouger les épaules comme ça
tranquillement alesi avait dit voilà à
tendre les bras devant ondes et les bras
devant on va boucher les mains comme ça
non pas les shakers s'il vous plaît
faliszek heures tout le monde tout le
monde y compris ceux qu'ont les shakers
mais sans les shakers ok ok on a levé
les bras on s'est tiré un peu déjà ça
fait du bien et puis en plus c'est la
meilleure manière de faire connaissance
avec son voisin partant des bras devant
devant devant devant devant ça fait mal
aux avant-bras là ça chauffe un peu
ok la frappe clair elle se fait sur les
djembés la main ouverte sur le bord de
la peau ok poser votre main voilà pour
les shakers elle se fait les doigts
ouvert pour laisser résonner les billes
ok donc on essaye après 4 une frappe
vous ensemble un deux trois casses
3 4 3 4 6 4 4 4 4
c'est top
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez pu avoir la maintenant une
petite expérience de ce que peut faire
le rythme et je vous fais une toute
confiance pour savoir quoi faire avec
les petits fours merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]